the city this morning Riding High with
vgk pride and folks are getting creative
you know yesterday we showed you tattoos
today something a little less permanent
our Lorna Grady join us live outside of
Vegas nailed and lashed that's at Sahara
and Durango and Lauren you are head to
Nails you've got that vtk spirit
yes a little less permanent than uh
tattoos there but still still fun I came
here yesterday and I got gilded just
before the game got my little helmet
there and my team colors as well you
know this actually was not their first
vgk request and Steph actually tell me
that with more sports teams coming to
Vegas the team spirit nails are a
growing trend
at Vegas nails and lash we're getting
the full vgk five-star treatment here
first up is applying the acrylics and
then we choose our team spirit design so
what is next in the process ah now we're
gonna ship them generally we do a lot of
the gold the black glitter we can have
our nail artists do jerseys hockey
sticks or helmets a lot of people like
the helmets on the nails and mostly As
long as they're long enough for us to
put those designs on them we've been
guilded with the biggest golden Knight
Nails okay so explain a little quick
what you did here this the the you got
the two spirit yeah we got
um the simple the golden Knight right
here and then we just do a little French
tip with some swirly line with the theme
color and yeah that's it that's what we
got here perfect beautiful biggest
golden night nails
okay so Danielle hooked it up here now
as far as like the price it really
depends on what you do you know the
designs the time spent the creativity
mine were about a little bit about a
hundred dollars there but you know
different price ranges again because I
have designs on each nail now again as
far as this plenty of ways to express
your vgk pride tattoos whether it's
pastries or Nails out here however you
want to do it live near Sahara and
Durango Lauren negretti 8 news now they
look so fantastic Lauren she showed me
up close this morning and this is
gorgeous yes taking one for the team
there Lauren nice
good job Lauren Nate you're up next